Hi and welcome to this
week's grammar spotlight.
Today we're going to talk about less
and fewer and when to use each one,
but in order to do that and we have to
talk about the nails that less and fewer
modify all nouns can be divided
into two categories and no,
we're not talking about
proper nouns and common nouns.
We're talking about countdowns and mass
nouns or non countdowns as their name
might suggest.
Countdowns are countable.
They can be pluralized by adding s and
they can take the indefinite article a
for example,
houses account down because I can count
it pluralize it and use a before it for
countdowns. Fewer as used.
Thus I have fewer houses,
fewer monkeys and 10 items or fewer
wait bass nailed or non count.
Nouns are nouns that cannot be divided
into countable units such as information.
Information cannot be counted,
cannot be pluralized by adding
this and cannot be used with a,
thus I have less information,
less homework and less furniture,
not fewer information's fewer
homeworks and fewer furnitures,
but be careful because there are words
that can be used as both countdowns and
mass nouns. Self for example, is
normally used as a mass known.
There is less salt on
the food than the table,
but in chemistry I might have fewer
salts than I'm accustomed to and now the
exceptions. What good would
the rule be without exceptions?
Less is often used in place of fewer
with dealing with expressions of
measurement and time,
so I make less than $12 an hour and
their child is less than two years old.
While there are some exceptions,
keeping in mind the general rule of fewer
for countdowns and less for non count
downs,
we'll give you a lot less heartache.
And in case you were wondering,
yes, this is a prescriptive rule.
Let's use to be considered perfectly
adequate for countdowns and mass nouns.
The injury for less than the
Oxford English dictionary
shows that as far back as
eight 88 eight d when we were
still speaking old English,
Lex was used with countdowns as well,
but that isn't the only example that
Oxford lists John Lilly and early modern
English rider of the 16th century
wrote the following in his book,
the Anatomy of wit.
I think there are a few universities
that have less false than Oxford.
Many that have more and yes,
those these in use and that the,
in our written correctly, at least for
16th century English. Until next time,
I hope you have less Sar
when fewer troubles than
usual this week or else fewer
sorrows in less trouble.
Both that usual, as I said,
some downs are both
countdowns and on countdowns.